kennt ihr das wenn die haare im sommer
belohnt werden mario wagner hat uns
gefragt warum haare im sommer helaba
gute frage besonders deutlich ist dieser
effekt bei blonden oder dunkelblonden
menschen zu erkennen deren haar im
sommer richtig hell wird aber selbst ich
bekomme im sommer zumindest ein paar
richtig hellbraune haare
woran liegt schauen wir uns doch erst
mal an was haare eigentlich sind haare
bestehen zum größten teil aus proteinen
vor allem das faser protein keratin
zwischen den keratin fasern die den
hauptteil des haares also den fahrer
stammen aus machen sitzen kleine
granulate aus melanie melanin sind
farbpigment es gibt zwei verschiedene
arten es gibt bäume melanin das sind
schwarz pigmente und es gibt tiere
melanie na das sind drohte und je nach
art zusammensetzung anzahl und größe
dieser melanin granulate also dieser
pigment granulate entstehen die
verschiedenen haarfarben schwarzhaarige
und projekte haben also mehr
melanie und blonde und rothaarige haben
mehr fehler meinen viele farbstoffe oder
pigmente haben dasselbe chemische
prinzip schauen uns mal die strukturen
hier haben wir eine neue mail an ihn
und hier haben wir ein chlorophyll
körperfülle das sind die grünen blatt
farbstoffe und wir sehen erstens dass
beide strukturen vier doppel bindungen
haben und wenn ihr genau hinschaut seht
ihr zweiter dass sich die doppelung
einfach bindungen immer abwechseln und
das nennt man ein korrigiertes system
und solche konjugierten systeme zeichnen
sich oft durch kräftige farben aus dem
sonnenlicht jetzt auf ein korrigiertes
system trifft geht es absorbiert
das heißt aufgenommen umso schützen uns
die melanin vor den schädlichen seiten
des sonnenlichts und darüber gehen sie
mit der zeit kaputt diesen vorgang nennt
man foto bleaching die männer sterben um
uns zu schützen darf man ihnen nicht so
robust sind die e mail gehen bei
helleren die pigmente schneller kaputt
und der effekt ist besser sichtbar in
der äussersten harzschicht sitzen
übrigens keine melanin hier werden durch
sonnenlicht vor allem aminosäuren
zerstört bei hellen wie auch bei dunklem
haar steckt sommers bis unsere haut
pigmente das sind übrigens auch melanie
hre warum wird dann unsere haut im
sommer dunkler und nicht helle kurze
antwort weil sie's km/h zellen sind tot
sie wachsen mit einer bestimmten anzahl
an medaillen aus dem kopf und wenn diese
dann durch die sonne zerstört werden
können wir nur darauf warten dass neue
nachwachsen die hautzellen leben aber
und die können auf das sonnenlicht
reagieren indem sie mehr melanin
produzieren um uns zu schützen und so
werden wir brauchen die männer linie
geben auf jeden fall ihr bestes um euch
flächendeckend zu schützen doch manchmal
ist alles was dabei rauskommt
sommersprossen jedenfalls wenn man eine
leiche in die sonne legen würde dann
würde ihre haut auch vergleichen
gut zu wissen
vielen dank mag das für deine fragen
wenn ihr noch fragen habt schreibt in
die kommentare
dann kann ich vielleicht auch mal in
einem video beantworten ansonsten sehen
wir uns nächste woche bis dahin bleibt
sicher